questi individui apple e google come si
dice a giocare in francese non sa petra
katz di oggi ragazzi volevo provare a
fare due robe carine voleva provare a
giocare con affari quiz su me stesso
sembra una cagata ma ci sono delle
domande su me stesso che le quali non
saprei dare neanche io risposta quindi
vediamo se riusciamo a fare la pace tv
prima domanda sull'inter non so
veramente ragazzi alle volte mi
debilitano certe cose quindi noto
esperimenti due punti quanti ne ha fatti
fino al 23 2017 3
meno male ho sparato anche perché molte
domande sono vecchia lettera quindi non
le so come si chiama libro di famiglia e
gianfranco dio mio
queste sono abbastanza easy dove era qui
è bellissimo perché ero agli universal
studios di los angeles dove avevo fatto
stars questo sketch con un minion
fighissimo ci sono anche tornato
quest'anno perché è stato un po strano e
con quella gli universal studios figli
siano quella volta lì la vj quante
ragazze ha avuto tre a ok ma perché non
so quando non so quante era giornata
sarastro quiz e soprattutto non so se in
quel preciso momento era comunque giusta
la risposta non dubito pietro conta una
ragazza cosa voglia fare finalmente dove
pietro non c'è
come no ai ragni ah beh sì è vero c'è un
ottimo conflitto tra i più in sei anni
allora andiamo avanti perché a vedere se
riesco a fare una roba decente comunque
per adesso abbastanza bene quante
canzoni ha fatto con ipantellas quante e
quante canzoni ma l'italiano più brutto
negli ultimi mille anni ha fatto video
su pokemon grossi malacca dove dove l'ho
persa verbo avere gol nuovo gioco di uno
hanno fatto anzi due forse come si
chiama il primo video di tre gli
acquisti di fa vj e bella domanda
quiz di quiz su fa vj e oggi è uguale le
facce dei video dei mille anni fa
chissà come era andato in quei bidoni
nomi ricordi quanti furono gli episodi
della serie d occhio o una domanda bella
non lo so
lohan che di fatto non lo so quanti
furono
credo sei credo ma 8 così tanti
beh non me lo ricordavo mai bella però
poi gay su youtube sta per raggiungere i
bell ore si lo so e 4 milioni belle
scelte domande vecchie ricevere un
profilo lista in prima di farvi j come
si chiamava chaffeur ma questo perché
sapete perchè perchè l'avevo copiato il
mio compagno che si chiamava shuffle
qualcosa allora mi piaceva e gli ho
rubato il nome praticamente a caso chi è
che gli fa una sorpresa a parigi il
giorno del suo compleanno aprile 2007
solo al power ai remember per giorno
storie la venuta a parigi e del mio
compleanno mi ha fatto una sorpresa
incredibile non me l'aspettavo
grazie subito lorenzo da chi ha preso
licheni fa vigili lo aveva eletto sulla
rivista da un giocatore di world awards
ho finalmente va comunque sarà questa
storia incredibile io l'ho rubuy a un
giocatore di motobarche serio fatto
proprio la juve lo stù nome l'ho preso e
mia famiglia e condivido affatto di epic
ecco questa non lo so perché dipende
quando hai fatto questa domanda credo
cento perché non ne ho mai fatti 250 nei
soli questo meno male perché ha fatto
questa reazione mamma mia che video ha
colpito un bicchiere
ragazzi io questo video era incredibile
perché avevo il nerf in mano il nerf per
sparare delle cose di spugna c'era un
bicchiere che stava su un armadio in
altissimo io pablo preso in pieno non so
come ma mira allucinante pazzesco ha
avuto star action se ogni volta che si
trova al saltato sul letto a caso dove
era qui fa vj o mio dio
empty non so spiegare il film enti pino
mi ricordavo mai come fa risponde alla
gente sa se domande non le so io
veramente quando la sabri gamer ha fatto
la penitenza dei social face nella
giostra chi c'era con lui e vegas
mi ricorderò mai ragazza cielo in posa
ma non mi ricordavo mai regalano le
soste risma colpa saperle la gente no
ragazzi sono certe risposte che sono
impossibili da sapere giuro come si
chiama questo video è un mio video
questo come usare un mago come non usare
un mago ma non è un mio video come non
usare un mago ma è un mio video non
sperino certo mio video a drakensang
mamma mia non mi ricordo ma non è mai
guardato qual è il suo cuore preferito
suo zap
ma non è vero o non è vero ma chi ha
scritto st roma perché il video di oggi
68 2016 proprio oggi è quel video
proprio mica son passati tre anni quanti
canestri ne fa nel gioco con le rane
io me lo ricordavo questo micro sparato
quando si è lanciato col paracadute
aveva delle scarpe ma dai ma che ne so
nere ma barba e culo incredibile perché
non mi ricordo solo quanti anni a fabi j
qualsiasi di queste risposte mi fa
venire il magone per 21 spero papi gay
non c'è
inizialmente avevo un canale questi due
amici perché poi la foto non proprio
perché non gli faceva lavorare con loro
li servirà il proprio tempo gli avevano
detto di andarsene i suoi video erano
più visti a herat a nessuna delle
quattro quindi mette una caso perché
nessuno nelle quattro gli serviva del
proprio tempo
il siviglia non più di ma non è vero ma
non c'entra niente e perché quando io
ero nel di share e gaming che facevo
video e avevo aperto la mia rubrica che
era giochi nel buio grandi horror
c'era tanta gente che si iscriveva solo
per quella rubrica che portavo solo io
quindi ho aperto fa vigili tv perché non
aveva senso portare in un canale di tre
persone video di una cosa che facevo
solo io allora ho aperto il mio canale
con loro poi continuato a fare per un po
di tempo ancora video inter però ragazzi
a fare un paio di quiz di calcio di non
so niente niente però ci proviamo
voglio vedere quanto riesco a ridere
quale giocatore è passato al mercato so
assolutamente di chi stai parlando
chiaramente esterni chiaramente era
l'altro naja la morte lo sapevo e
ragazzi da sempre vedere se eravate
attendere chi è stato promosso
direttamente nella stagione della serie
b da porco arakan si legge che è stato
promosso direttamente dalla serie b alla
serie a nella stagione 2000 e qui taglia
di crotone
mamma mia mamma mia crowe topo al saa
crotone al e tutto il settore impazzisce
per te ovunque andrai ti seguirò e mai
ti lascerò bar dove giocava welbeck
prima di approdare alla all'arsenal non
so neanche chi sia manchester ma porca
vacca porca cristiano ronaldo e dio sa
portoghese questo lo sapevo lo sapevo
facciamo di cultura generale se da apple
volo è proprio per vedere come nella
cavicchio dove si trova la spezia in
lingua
mamma mia come la sola geografia solo
quello il personaggio è un wade
henderson che fa di sicuro non il
parrucchiere o lo so il banchiere
regista facili quali sono i colori della
squadra di calcio
rossoblù che questa cultura generale non
ero sul calcio finchè non sbaglio
ragazzi la continuità qual è il nome
scientifico della corsa amicus sicuro
galloprovincialis regionale scalo
nazionali tipo non prega cozza e basta
ancora uno ancora meno ragazzi che non
sbaglia ancora una mela devo sentirmi ad
almeno 32 giusta e devo fare ci provo
quante declinazioni allattino va bene
che però mi volete male porco demonio
mangano rimangono studiato latino io
faccio informatica non studiamo neanche
quella prova bene proprio lui
habemus latinu che animale è pietro alla
zebra zebra allo yen a bardotto cammello
febbraio al diavolo ma è vero
10 di un cavallo memento audere semper
frase latina cosa significa agire ma
vabbè ragazzi questo era il mio quiz di
oggi molto strano però mi diverte
tantissimo per i quiz pero vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi sono molto mi piace
fare i quiz divertente perché ti
scioglie il cervello quel poco che ne è
rimasto però vi sia piaciuto come siete
ragazzi avete piaciuto a 120 m like che
avrei social che come noi in totale la
descrizione se non si discute è come
sempre ragazzi ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]